bill clinton returns from the grave to
give a keynote john kerry arrives fresh
off his foreign policy failures so
lecture americans
and aoc checks off every single sjw
bingo box
inside of one minute i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe
at expressvpn.com ben we have a lot to
get to today we'll get to all of it in
just one second first
a great reminder you may have noticed
that it's getting hot out there
in a lot of place in california it's so
hot we've got rolling blackouts well now
would have been a good time for you to
get some good window coverings like some
good shades
you got the old blinds they aren't
working particularly well you need to
replace those you need to upgrade the
look and feel of your home
and your comfort level this is why you
need blinds.com blinds.com makes it
simple to shop
top quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping the experts
at blinds.com understand that window
treatments are one of the household
items you just don't think very much
about
but they can make a huge impact on the
look and feel of your home you don't
need a full renovation
by simply changing what's on your
windows you can create a totally
different feel the way light comes into
the room go to blinds.com take a look at
all their awesome options they have the
faux wood blinds the cellular the roller
shades
even outdoor shades if you're nervous
about trying them there's no reason to
be because they've helped millions of
homeowners through the process
and they guarantee the perfect fit
whether you do it yourself or whether
you have them measure and install
everything
directly for you go right now see how
much you can save at blinds.com rules
and restrictions
may apply go check them out right now at
blinds.com again
great way to upgrade look and feel your
home and save on electricity bills in
many cases go check them out at
blinds.com that's blinds.com
alrighty so night two democratic
national convention
excitement on the order of the reaction
to the finale of lost
i mean just endless levels of excitement
how exciting has this convention been
well knight one was down 28
year on year it turns out that running a
bunch of bad youtube videos in a row
really doesn't do it
for people and while michelle obama was
indeed a draw knight two did not feature
michelle obama
knight two featured a bunch of
democratic retreads talking about their
crappy foreign policy perspectives
and making selfless
completely un non-self-aware comments
about politics i mean that really was
the theme was non-ironic
unaware comments about politics last
night from a variety of democratic
figures just saying things
that can be characterized as gaslighting
gaslighting for those who don't know
is a phenomenon wherein you drive
somebody crazy by pretending something
isn't happening
happening that definitely is happening
it comes from a movie called gaslight
starring ingrid bergman going all the
way back in which it's at least charles
boyer charles boye plays ingrid
bergman's husband
and he wants to drive her nuts and so
every night he turns down the gas lights
in the house
and then she says have you turned down
the gas like he says no everything is
fine nothing has changed right that's
that's gaslighting that's where the
the phrase comes from last night was
example par excellence of gaslighting
and
you got to feel in american politics
like one of the things that's happening
is the insane amount of gaslighting on
all sides
really is pretty crazy i mean the best
example of gaslighting that i've seen
continues to be the media's
willingness to prop up andrew cuomo the
worst governor in america
that stupid ass is now being given a
book contract to write about kovid
his st it's like the captain of the
titanic being contracted to write
about proper navigation of the oceans
the the thing is called american crisis
it's called american crisis
and they released the book cover and
it's just a picture of andrew cuomo
on the book cover looking all stern and
leadery
okay again it's called the american
crisis it really should be called if i
did it
like the o.j simpson book if i did it so
we're being gaslit
on a variety of issues and the gas
lighting was on full display at the dnc
it's been on full display at the dnc
the dnc continues to be a radical
organization but then
the leadership of the nc will pretend
that it's not a radical organization
so for example linda sarsour right linda
sarsour is a radical
anti-semite a person who has spoken in
defense of terrorists before
she's exorbitantly anti-semitic i mean
really dislikes jews
and she is a muslim delegate to the dnc
she didn't have like an official
appearance it's not like they slated her
for a speaking role but she appeared
at one of the daytime sessions
apparently from some sort of
hotel room for the dnc caucus and
council meeting as a muslim delegate
and allies assembly and suggested that
the dnc
was basically run by people like her
and she actually said that the dnc
stands with us stands with us which is
kind of true
okay i mean it's been true for quite a
while by the way i was there at the 2012
democratic convention at which the
democrats from the floor
overruled what was obviously a majority
of the delegates
in trying to remove jerusalem as
israel's capital from the dnc
platform sarsour her appearance in this
little caucus video
it actually caused the biden campaign to
come out and condemn linda sarsour
because they they understand
where their bread is buttered in terms
of american politics linda sarsour is is
not a particularly popular figure
on any side of the aisle except the
radical left a biden spokesman named
andrew bates said joe biden has been a
strong supporter of israel and a
vehement opponent of anti-semitism his
entire life
he obviously condemns her views and
opposes bds as does the democratic
platform she has no role
in the biden campaign whatsoever okay so
there's a bit of gaslighting she's still
a delegate right she's still saying that
the party
is her party and she's still hobnobbing
with people like aoc
right she's never been disavowed by
members of the squad of course and she
won't be disavowed by any members
of the squad other examples of
gaslighting yesterday at the dnc in sort
of the lead up to the prime time
again i paid more attention than i think
most people to the stuff before the
prime time because again the prime time
is the dating profile
and the stuff that happens during the
day is the actual on the ground
grassroots democratic party
at work elizabeth warren spoke to the
dnc's native american caucus
which is like i can't think of anything
more tone deaf than that
elizabeth warren fake native american
who claimed native american ancestry to
get ahead in her career
was speaking on behalf of the dnc to
native americans it was real
real weird so that's a bit of
gaslighting
as well okay so finally we get to prime
time and we get the cavalcade of comedy
stars
from the dnc we get a bunch of democrats
coming out and saying stuff
that it's almost impossible to believe
that they don't understand the irony of
what they are saying
they're just brought out figure after
figure to say things that are in direct
contravention of things these people
have done to take a perfect example
governor stacey abrams of georgia i
speak ironically of course because she
is not actually governor of georgia but
believes she is despite the fact she
lost my 50 000 votes
in georgia and she's been wandering the
streets ever since claiming to be the
governor of georgia
now apparently i'm just shocked she
didn't declare herself the vice
presidential nominee in this particular
little speech so she spoke at the at the
dnc
in this little online convention they're
having and she said
we're going to work to stop voter
suppression she talked about the
undermining of elections
now this has been her stick for quite a
while is that our elections are being
undermined
she's literally been going around for
years at this point
claiming that she won an election she
lost by 50 000 votes and she or she is
talking about electoral integrity
stacey abrams again the fact that this
woman was even considered for vp
demonstrates what a joke the democratic
party is at the highest levels here's
stacey abrams
joe biden is a man of proven courage
he will restore our moral compass by
confronting our challenges
not by hiding from them or undermining
our elections
to keep his job in a time of voter
suppression at home
and authoritarians abroad joe biden will
be a champion
for free and fair elections trump is
undermining elections unlike stacey
abrams who goes around
claiming without any basis whatsoever
that the vote was suppressed in georgia
so that was a bit of irony that we are
just not really allowed to note
according to the media
and then we got sally yates so sally
gates is the former acting attorney
general
you'll recall that sally yates was fired
by the trump administration because
trump
believed as it turns out sort of
correctly that sally yates was oriented
against the trump administration
sally yates it is also worth noting has
testified publicly at this point that
she was shocked to learn
in the early days of the of the incoming
trump administration the outgoing obama
administration that barack obama and joe
biden were full in
in knowledge with regard to michael
flynn and the pursuit of michael flynn
right sally yates has said that she was
shocked that james comey was not fully
informing the trump team about the fact
that they're investigating michael flynn
and that she was shocked to learn
that joe biden and barack obama were
fully informed and in the loop
on an investigation into michael flynn
and that's essentially what she has
suggested in front of congress
yet here with sally yates suggesting
that donald trump is attacking our
institutions
when she's literally testified that she
was part of an administration that was
attacking
basic institutions like you don't sick
your intelligence sources on your
incoming
administration that you dislike here's
sally yates though talking about
undermining american institutions
his constant attacks on the fbi the free
press
inspectors general federal judges they
all have one purpose
to remove any check on his abuse of
power
put simply he treats our country
like it's his family business this time
bankrupting our nation's moral authority
by the way she's been a long time
democratic donor so she started this
thing off by saying i'm not really a
political figure i'm a more illegal
figure
she's been giving democrats for for a
very long time sally yates testifying
about institutional abuses
while she was in the obama
administration which was institutionally
abusing
michael flynn institutionally abusing
carter page
kind of ironic we'll get to more ironies
from the democratic national convention
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that right now a lot of
people are looking at the news and
thinking can i even get life insurance
right now is that even a possibility the
answer of course
is yes it is still easy to shop for life
insurance right now if you have loved
ones depending on your income you
probably should right now
you could save 1500 bucks or more per
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies
whether you're shopping for a policy
that could last for a decade or more or
not
you should be checking out policy genius
to competitively shop what is policy
genius it's an insurance marketplace and
they make it really easy step one you
head on over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price
step two you can apply for your lowest
price step three the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape
policy genius works for you not the
insurance company so if you run into any
speed bumps they will handle it for you
and iron the whole thing out
they even have policies that allow
eligible customers to skip in-person
medical exams and do it over the phone
which is why policy genius has a
five-star rating across 1600 reviews on
trustpilot and google so
if you need life insurance because
you're a responsible human being want to
make sure that your family is taken care
of in case god forbid you should plot
head on over to policygenius.com right
now to get started you could save 1500
bucks or more a year by comparing quotes
on their marketplace policy genius when
it comes to insurance it is nice
to get it right okay so meanwhile
speaking of gaslighting
again the dnc is claiming that joe biden
is a deeply moderate candidate that
their party is deeply moderate
so moderate in fact that they are
willing to disavow linda sarsour and all
of this
and then they trot out aoc and aoc
i will say this for aoc the woman can
compress more
sjw slogans into a short period of time
than any person alive it is truly an
incredible skill
if you had a bingo card drinking game
you were dead of alcohol poisoning
inside of a minute
she had 60 minutes 60 seconds to express
herself and she hits
every single square on the sjw
democratic socialist of america marxist
bingo card i mean just
one after another it's pretty
astonishing she's like the auctioneer
of sjw nonsense so here is aoc she did
the pro forma nomination of bernie
sanders some people got this wrong
suggesting that she was
trying to undermine binding that's not
the way this works in honor of the
person who finished second there's
always somebody who nominates that
person to the presidency
here was aoc just spitting out spitting
some hot lyrics
about racial injustice colonization
misogyny
infidelity and gratitude to a mass
people's movement
working to establish 21st century social
economic and human rights including
guaranteed health care
higher education living wages and labor
rights
for all people in the united states
a movement striving to recognize and
repair
the wounds of racial injustice
colonization
misogyny and homophobia drink
okay so then she she went on with that
but you're already dead of alcohol
poisoning it's too late
this is why you really need to have like
a smirnoff iced drinking games with aoc
when it comes to
sjw kind of crap did you get all of that
racial injustice colonization misogyny
homophobia we're gonna heal all those
wounds through bernie sanders okay so
don't worry not a radical party aoc is
just the leader of a newfangled squad
that is gaining members
by the election they've gained two new
members to the squad they have uh a
woman who is a social justice
activist a michael brown protester
turned
congress person over in missouri and
then they have a person who
got rid of elliot engel over in new york
basically because eliot angle was
pro-israel
so very exciting stuff the squad
continues to grow inside the democratic
party but don't worry
it is a moderate party and then the
gaslighting continued
chuck schumer the senate minority leader
arrived to explain
that president trump has divided the
country now let it be known
that chuck schumer is currently in the
senate holding up
any deal that will allow anybody to get
increased aid from the government in a
time of government shutdowns
specifically because he and nancy pelosi
have combined to push a 3.4
trillion dollar pork package that pays
off all of the various democratic
priorities
from the post office to various union
interests okay they're holding it up
purely and specifically because they
want that deal not to happen because
then trump might get credit and the
economy might be upheld
instead they're openly rooting for
failure don't worry chuck schumer isn't
the one who's divisive
chuck schumer and his democrats aren't
the ones who are divisive only donald
trump is divisive
now as i've said before whatever you
think about trump and his divisiveness
and there's no question
he's a divisive figure the fact is that
trump when it comes to american politics
is not the murderer he is the coroner
chuck schumer has been in washington dc
since the times of abraham lincoln
chuck schumer has contributed more to
polarization in washington
over the course of his career than
donald trump has over the course of the
last four years for certain here is
chuck schumer talking about divisions in
the country which can be healed by chuck
schumer in some way here is chuck
schumer
a a pretty gross politician if ever
we've seen one here is chuck schumer
the statue of liberty the same site
that greeted hopeful immigrants like my
grandparents
a symbol of freedom and a beacon of hope
to the world
today donald trump has divided our
country
diminished our greatness and demeaned
everything
that this statue represents he even hid
in a bunker
as americans were tear gassed and beaten
okay come come on i mean they're
focusing purely in on on the
the lafayette square incident this has
become the big talking point is
lafayette square incident which by the
way is under dispute as to whether
protesters were actually attacking
members of the park service and all that
the studious avoidance of things that
are actually going on in the country on
a wide scale is pretty incredible
portland doesn't exist poof seattle
doesn't exist poof
la it doesn't exist chicago doesn't
exist new york doesn't exist washington
dc doesn't exist
none of this exists according to the
democrats so who are you going to
believe
chuck schumer standing in front of the
statue of liberty in the dark in a shut
down city
or your own eyes which one are you gonna
believe don't worry trump is the really
divisive force here all you have to do
is elect the democrats and the riots
will stop which by the way is the tacit
promise here right we all know what the
tacit promise here the tacit promise
here is
that if the democrats get what they want
and donald trump leaves office
then the riots and the big cities will
stop then the lockdowns will gradually
end there's a new york times
article by the way just a couple of days
ago talking about the shutdowns of
public education
there are new studies out suggesting
that kids under the age of 10 really are
not transmitting this to parents
like in any mass numbers and that even
kids above the age of 10
are not transmitting this in the same
kinds of numbers as fully grown adults
hey there's not a good reason why
schools should be shut down at this
point
schools are open across europe schools
are open across asia
schools are open in canada schools are
take some precautions open the schools
even new york is looking at opening the
schools but the new york times
acknowledged that
much of the reason that a lot of schools
are closed is because democrats have
decided that if trump wants the schools
open the schools
must be closed and at some point trump
has got to start engaging in some
reverse psychology
with these people and simply advocate
for complete and endless shutdowns so
the democrats will start advocating for
opening up the economy again
but it it is fairly incredible that
chuck schumer and and the democrats
continue to claim
that all of the bad things that are
happening are donald trump's fault all
you have to do
is elect us and then we will leave you
alone it's really a reflection of 1960s
politics
i was listening to another podcast
yesterday the commentary magazine
podcast which is quite good
and uh and always interesting and they
were they were amusing over the fact
that the democratic national convention
if you look at the way that they label
various people at the dnc they're
constantly labeling people activists
and they no longer label them by their
sort of political title
they now label them activists right the
cory bush who's the woman who just won
in in missouri in this fraught district
uh
she is an activist right aoc likes to
think of herself as an activist you have
a lot of government officials
in the democratic party who consider
themselves activists well activists
define themselves by opposition to the
system
and so what's really happening here is
that the democrats are playing an inside
outside game
the inside outside game is they pretend
that they are activists who are shaping
the system
from the outside while simultaneously
taking over the institutions so they can
make concessions to the activist side
and this has been happening on college
campuses for years where you have
administrators who used to be activists
caving to the newfangled activists who
then become the administrators who then
cave to the newfangled activists
is how you constantly push to the left
this is what happened in major cities in
the 1960s
there's a there's a great book by a man
named fred siegel one of the founders of
the manhattan institute
called the future once happened here
talking about the decline of america's
major cities in the 1960s
and one of the major forces that led to
that was the inside outside game being
played
by rioters looters and quote unquote
activists outside the government
pushing members of the government and
members of the government would openly
acknowledge they would openly say
we're so glad we have these activists
outside creating chaos so that we have
to cave to the chaos
well you shouldn't be blackmailed into
voting for democrats
you should not be blackmailed into
voting for democrats by watching as
democrats foster chaos in america's
major cities as they talk about
defunding the police
as they talk about making room for
people to riot and loot
and then they suggest you know what all
of this will go away just give us more
power
okay that is an ugly tactic but it is a
tactic that is indeed happening
the same democrats who are suggesting
guys you know these lockdowns they're
really really really necessary but if
you elect us then we'll solve it and
then
the lockdowns will just go away the
tacit promise is we will stop opposing
you being able to do your job and do
your business so long as you elect
us that's a blackmail threat it really
is and you shouldn't cave to it
if you're a free thinking american you
should not cave to anybody telling you
that you cannot take advantage of your
rights unless you elect them
that's a pretty ugly pitch it will get
you more of democratic hypocrisy
from the dnc last night and again
trotting out just some
really old retreads really old redreds
we'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about your
mouth health so you may be thinking you
know what
you know okay so i don't brush my teeth
as often as the dentist says i'm
supposed to
is that really going to kill me yes the
answer is definitely good
i mean the fact is that your mouth
health is connected to things like your
heart health for example and this is why
you need a toothbrush that is actually
going to do a good job of cleaning your
teeth this is why you need quip the quip
smart brush for adults and kids
connects to the quip app with bluetooth
bluetooth it will track when and how
well you brush
you can get tips and coaching to improve
your habits you earn points for daily
brushing which makes it fun
for you and for the kids and bonus
points competing completing challenges
like streaks like you do several days in
a row you can regime for awards like
free products gift cards and discounts
from quip and partners if you already
have equip
you can upgrade it with a smart motor
and keep the features you know and love
those sensitive sonic vibrations the two
minute timer with 30 second pulses so
you have the guided clean make sure that
you're doing exactly what the dentist
thinks
you should it's slim it's lightweight
it's sleek it's great for travel
it's not one of those big bulky ones
with a big charger join over five
million mouths who use quip
save hundreds compared to other
bluetooth brushes when you get equip
smart brush for just 45 bucks
start getting rewards for brushing your
teeth today go to getquip.com
shapiro right now get your first refill
for free again get your first refill
free at get quip dot com slash shapiro
it's spelled
g-e-t q-u-i-p dot com shapiro quip
better oral health made simple and
rewarding go check them out right now
it's a great toothbrush a great product
get
quip.com shapiro for your first refill
free and again that's the other feature
they send you the refills
so you never have to think about when
you need new stuff get quip handles it
for you go check them out right now okay
so
it wasn't just chuck schumer and aoc i
mean so many luminaries
it was luminaries like jimmy carter so
jimmy cara has shown up again now
i'm glad that jimmy carter does nice
things for the homeless like building
houses for the homeless
that's a nice thing he was also one of
the worst presidents in american history
truly an awful president a president who
presided over the decline of american
power abroad
led to the rise of the soviet union in
afghanistan led to the iranian takeover
of the american embassy
facilitated the rise of the ayatollahs
which we are still feeling the impact of
jimmy carter presided over stagflation
he was an awful president he was such a
bad president that
he got absolutely walloped by ronald
reagan who was considered the underdog
when that race started and so jimmy
carter was a disastrous
president he's been a disastrous
post-president by the way in his
politics this is a guy who's made
overtures to hamas the terrorist group
this is a man who in the aftermath of
his presidency
spoke with the soviets openly about how
terrible
the the the reagan administration was
jimmy carter has been a disaster on
foreign policy for a long time now last
night was the foreign policy night of
the convention this very often
is the pattern you have sort of a an
introductory night then you have the
foreign policy night and then you have
the vp night and then you have the
presidential night
that's that's usually the pattern so
tonight is the vp nights we get to hear
from
kamala harris and her joker laugh okay
well we'll get to hear some of that
maybe we won't get to hear that tonight
because kamala harris isn't being asked
to have questions
tonight anyway jimmy carter was trotted
forth to endorse
and i'm old enough to remember in 2004
when jimmy carter was sitting in the
presidential box with michael moore
which shows you where
jimmy carter actually sits on politics
just because the man is
quite elderly does not mean that he was
a good president or that he has pursued
in any way
anything remotely approaching a moral
foreign policy he never has and so
having him speak on foreign policy
tonight is quite the achievement
here was jimmy carter endorsing joe
biden who by the way for the record has
been wrong on every major foreign policy
issue of his lifetime
it is impressive i mean it like they say
that a stopped clock is right twice a
day
joe biden has yet to be right he's not
actually a stop he's
just moving very very very slowly so he
has never actually been right it's
it's incredible you you have to be like
like even if you just fill in c on all
the bubbles of the s.a.t you'll end up
getting a couple of those questions
right
somehow joe biden has studiously avoided
being right his entire career on foreign
policy
anyway here was jimmy carter endorsing
him
when i ran for president in 1976 joe
biden was my first and most effective
supporter in the senate
for decades he has been my loyal and
dedicated friend
joe has the experience character and
decency to bring us together
and restore america's greatness in these
uncertain times
nobody realizes that many american lives
can be saved each day
through the use of mass and testing as
recommended by our medical experts
joe biden must be our next president
okay great jimmy i need to hear who
needs to be the next president from
jimmy carter i mean that is a sterling
recommendation from
a man who is literally one of the five
worst presidents in the history of the
united states so that that is very very
exciting
stuff okay then we got bill clinton
okay so i'm old enough to remember when
the democratic party was the me too
party believe all
women believe all women justice brett
kavanaugh was probably a rapist based on
no evidence
whatsoever other than an account that
was disputed by every single other
person who's mentioned in the account
from
christine blasey ford i'm old enough to
remember
when the democratic party was declaring
that anyone
everyone who is accused of a thing had
to go in fact in that brief moment there
was some talk in the democratic party
about how bill clinton was done right
bill clinton had to go
right there was talk in this newfangled
democratic party
about how if they could go back in time
they really would have rethought that
whole lewinsky paula jones
juanita broderick thing and maybe they
would have thought twice about clinton
well now they thought twice about
thinking twice so bill clinton got
trotted out
to give again one of the least
self-aware speeches in the history
of a of a convention so we're going to
get into the
non-ironic speech by bill clinton like
did he run it by anybody before he said
it out loud we'll get to that in just
one second first
let us talk about the fact that now is
not a great time to go to the auto parts
store in fact that never is a great time
to go to the auto parts store instead
you should be using the magic of the
interwebs why would you not the
interwebs is great
rockauto.com it is much easier than
walking into a store and someone's
demanding
quick answers to questions like is your
odyssey an lx or an ex
and then they probably don't have the
part and even if they do have the part
it's generic but they probably have to
order it online anyway and then they
upcharge you instead just go to
rockauto.com and cut out the middleman
they always offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear
like airlines do why would you spend up
to twice as much for the same
parts i mean that's that's literally the
case in many cases you can go to rock
auto and you're getting like 40 50
off the ticket price at a big auto parts
store rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com they're always
reliably low they are the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers so
you shouldn't spend
more on the same parts it's just silly
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available
for your car or truck right shapiro in
there how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you
rockauto.com right now remember to write
shapiro in that how did you hear about
xbox so they know that we sent you that
helps us and it helps them as well
by the way you should do this for all of
our sponsors so they know that they
should continue to advertise and also so
they know that
you're listening to the show we really
appreciate it go check out rockauto.com
right now okay so bill mcclinton
so it's awkward it's awkward now there
were some people who were being asked
questions about
all of this so for example tammy
duckworth who's not picked is the vice
presidential pick
she was asked about why bill clinton was
speaking at the dnc
and she was like well it's a big tent a
big ol rapey tent
so that's that's good stuff and then we
had jennifer granholm
the former governor of michigan
explaining
why bill clinton has not been cancelled
yet and it got awkward because there is
no good reason why bill clinton has not
been canceled yet
here was uh here this happened on cnn
here was
jennifer granholm trying to awkwardly
explain why
captain rapy mc epstein was was up there
on the dnc stage
how is it that bill clinton has not been
canceled by the democratic how has he
survived all of these waves of
cancellation when he has been one of the
biggest violators of these
rules
okay this has already been asked and
answered
decades ago the point is that bill
clinton
is excellent at explaining stuff
especially the things that matter to
everyday people
what i admire about bill clinton is that
he has
acknowledged his wrongdoing
he has acknowledged his wrongdoing in
what way in what way has he acknowledged
his wrongdoing
exactly van jones i love jennifer graham
this happened a long time ago well i
don't know should we
should grab his high school high school
yearbooks and ask about boofing i'm old
enough to remember because i'm more than
two years old when they asked brett
kavanaugh what the devil's triangle was
in in his high school yearbook
description and he had to bring forth
his calendars from high school
which was then seen as a mark of white
supremacy and privilege
yes i'm old enough to remember all of
that but bill clinton it happened a long
time ago guys i mean just because he was
kind of like a little rapey like a lot
for like a lot of women
and there are dozens of allegations
against him that are dicey
come on guys bill clinton's still a good
guy i mean it's a long time ago
i i do love the democratic changing
standard it's pretty
astonishing it really is pretty great
okay so then bill clinton gives his
speech
and bill clinton is not looking as good
as he did back in 2012. you remember the
bill clinton gave this much ballyhooed
speech at the
2012 democratic national convention on
behalf of barack obama barack obama came
out and gave him a real awkward bro hug
afterward
okay so last night bill clinton gave his
speech
and he talked about why donald trump is
now qualified to be president
the pressures of the job and without any
sense of irony or self-awareness at all
he started making references to the oval
office so here was bill mcclinton
rapey mcplain a lot here he was at a
time like this
the oval office should be a command
center instead it's a storm center
there's only chaos just one thing never
changes
his determination to deny responsibility
and shift the blame
the buck never stops there
the oval office is a storm center and
the buck never stops with him okay so
when you're gonna talk about using the
oval office as a storm center
i don't think that bill clinton means it
the same way that he thinks he
means it i mean he was literally banging
the interns in the oval office guy's
hey like right there in the oval office
it got
real awkward on that rug under the desk
so that was um that yeah bill clinton
talking about the oval office of the dnc
real real weird um so there was that
that was that was the thing that
happened last night at the dnc and then
bill clinton was like
we can't trust donald trump because that
man is not really i do also like when he
says the buck always stops at the top
i mean there are literal allegations
that
bill clinton was basically launching
wars in order to avoid responsibility
for nailing the help
anyway here's bill clinton talking about
people being distracted at their jobs he
was like we we need people who are
focused in like a laser beam on the job
of being president of the united states
so here was bill from chappaqua this is
the first time he's been back to chapel
cline years i mean he and hillary
clinton studiously
avoid each other and they they're
they're like
joe frazier and muhammad ali just
despise one another trying to stay away
from each other but
locked in eternal combat here is bill
clinton talking about uh defining the
job of the presidency
denying distracting and demeaning works
great if you're trying to entertain or
inflame
but in a real crisis it collapses like a
house of cards
kovit just doesn't respond to any of
that
to beat it you've got to actually go to
work and deal with the facts
right we can't deny and we can't
distract we can't say like for example
that we didn't bang the help uh we we we
really we really can't say things like
there's a vast right-wing conspiracy to
get me and that that is why it doesn't
matter that i'm nailing the interns
um yeah bill clinton and then he says
that
president trump defines his job as
tweeting and you can't find the job as
tweeting
because that's in the job the job is
definitely receiving oral sex in the
oval office i mean that's the job guys
and if anyone knows that it's bill
clinton here's bill clinton defining the
job of the presidency
now you have to decide whether to renew
his contract or hire someone else
if you want a president who defines the
job of spending hours a day watching tv
and zapping people on social media he's
your man
and if you want somebody who spends
hours a day
checking out the thongs of the 18 year
olds who staff his office
we did that for two terms so it seems
like americans have a kind of variegated
view on the presidency hey so they tried
it out bill clinton that was awkward
then
i mean speaking of just people who have
not been relevant and are not relevant
and are terrible at their jobs
to be to try you know trotting these
people out to endorse john kerry was
brought forth
john kerry reporting for duty
face collapsing like a mudslide in the
beverly
hills during a rainstorm el nino
have means that i'm collapsing from
within
worst secretary of state in american
history so he showed up
to to talk about his brilliant foreign
policy we'll get to that in just one
minute because that is obviously
very very solid stuff we'll get to that
in a moment first let us talk about the
fact that you really need to protect
your online data
right from viruses from malware from
ransomware
pcmatic this is the next generation
antivirus designed to stop modern
threats like ransomware
an independent testing from av test just
named pcmatic as a top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019. only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is often foreign
made sometimes in countries where the
malware actually comes from
pcmatic will block annoying malicious
ads for hassle-free web browsing and
makes your computers faster and more
reliable even after years of use
pcmatic protects windows computers
including xp visto vista windows 7 8 and
windows servers max macbooks and android
phones and tablets
pcmatic is just 50 bucks for five
devices for one year with a full 30 day
money back
guarantee if you act right now pc mac
has offered my listeners a free month of
security protection with the purchase of
an annual license which is a great deal
you got to protect your data if you've
ever had your data stolen it is no fun
at all pcmatic is really sophisticated
and they're doing a great job of
protecting the information you need
protected to access this offer go to
pcmatic.com
ben again to get the world-class
security that keeps your computer
running great go to pcmatic.com and make
the magic happen
for yourself right this moment okay
we're going to continue
with john kerr reporting for duty
in one second first i want to tell you
about our most exclusive membership tier
over at daily wire all access
all access members get to join the all
access live that's our exclusive live
stream discussions hosted each night by
each of the hosts
including me it gets real weird we tell
dad jokes
best dad joke last night we have like a
running competition in the all-access
live
best dad joke last night what is green
and fuzzy and will kill you if it falls
from a tree
ready a pool table that's the kind of
gold you're gonna get when you're an
all-access member hanging out with me
and wearing t-shirts tomorrow night
august 20th we'll be doing a very
special live stream watch party covering
the dnc's biggest speakers with the
daily wires own matt walsh she was
sacrificing he's throwing himself on
that political grenade
just for your viewing pleasure the
stream starts at 8 45 pm eastern 5 45 pm
pacific so don't miss this big
opportunity
to watch matt loki mock the final night
of the dnc all access membership
also features exclusive access to live
online discussions with our hosts
writers special guests along with not
one
but two count them two leftist tears
tumblers with your membership as well as
early sometimes exclusive access to new
daily wire podcasts
so head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now to get 20
off all access with coupon code access
that is dailywire.com
shapiro with coupon code access get 20
off your membership
also we have celebrated daily wire
backstage it's happening
this very friday 4 p.m pacific i'm so
excited
so excited i'm not being forced to read
that i'm excited at all but
we are doing it and there's a lot to
discuss check us out on backstage i will
watch the others
smoke their cigars and drink their
whiskey and i will have girly drinks
the collective force of the daily wear
will attempt to make sense of all the
bizarre events
happening in our world again that is 4
p.m pacific this friday so come
join us over at dailywire.com right now
again 20
off all access when you get an all
access pass right now you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
alrighty so we get to john kerry so
again the democrats trotted out people
who just have a bad record to talk about
why you should like why you should
listen to them which makes no sense at
all so john kerry the worst secretary of
state
in modern american history helped broker
the garbage iran deal undermined
alliances with israel
horrible policy on afghanistan horrible
policy with regard to the middle east
horrible policy on china absolutely cow
towing to russia on syria
i mean just a garbage heap of a
secretary of state an awful secretary of
state
we need to hear from him about why
the foreign policy of joe biden will be
correct now again joe biden has yet to
make a correct foreign policy decision
his entire career
he literally has none his big theory is
that we should just divide up countries
he said it about afghanistan he said it
about iraq
like that was his big theory his going
theory he's so bad at politics
that this after the trump administration
brokered this israel uae deal which is a
real historic breakthrough
biden tried to take credit by claiming
that he had had conversations with the
uae while he was vp
joe biden's last conversation with the
uae happened in 2014 and it ended with
him having to issue an official apology
to the government of the uae
that's how good joe biden is at
diplomacy john kerry is so good at
diplomacy that his unintentional
his the the unintentional effects of his
butt kissing
of the iranian regime ended with the
creation of a pro-israel alliance in the
middle east now
so thank you john kerry so anyway john
kerry goes out and he gives a speech
john kerr
about why american troops don't trust
donald trump now
okay if we have to ask american soldiers
and service people overseas and at home
whether they trust
john kerry over say donald trump
that is not a close call john kerry is a
person who testified that american
soldiers
in vietnam were war criminals who
supposedly threw his own medals over the
white house fence in protest
at american soldiers so listening to
john kerry lecture us on the troops is
really
ironic and rich kind of like bill
clinton lecturing us on honor in the
oval office here was john kerry doing
this routine
this is the bottom line our interests
our ideals and our brave men and women
in uniform
can't afford four more years of donald
trump
our troops can't get out of harm's way
by hiding in the white house bunker
they need a president who will stand up
for them
and president biden will oh so
i'm going to listen to this guy this
schmuck who suggested that american
soldiers routinely taping electrodes to
genitals
of vietnamese people in order to garner
information during the vietnam
war cutting off ears this is literally
what he testified in the winter soldier
testimony i hear that schmuck
talk about what's best for american
troops yeah let's listen to john kerry
and then he says when trump goes
overseas it's a blooper reel yeah as
opposed to when barack obama went
overseas and just apologized for
america's presence on the world stage
repeatedly
that was great or when john kerry went
overseas and
literally undermined american alliances
or when joe biden went overseas and
literally had to apologize to people he
was talking to
here was john kerry talking up biden's
foreign policy for some reason
donald trump inherited a growing economy
and a more peaceful world
and like everything else he inherited he
bankrupted it
when this president goes overseas it
isn't a goodwill mission it's a blooper
reel
he breaks up with our allies and writes
love letters to dictators
america deserves a president who is
looked up to
not laughed at oh is that okay
well as opposed to barack obama who has
looked up again who looked up to barack
obama overseas except for leftists
overseas who want to see america shrink
its role in the world
and the fact is that whatever you can
say about donald trump
china is more fearful of the united
states today because trump is president
of biden war and that's been made
obvious and clear there are intelligence
reports suggesting china's trying to
interfere in our elections
on behalf of joe biden same thing with
iran and when it comes to russia
i'm old enough to remember when barack
obama was pledging flexibility to the
russians and letting them take over
crimea
so good times good times okay and then
they they went even further it's like
who else can we bring out here who has a
poor foreign policy record how do we
bring out colin powell
who's been widely derided by both right
and left for the speech that he made in
front of you on making the case for war
and rock
now colin powell is good again because
the way that people become good again is
simply to oppose trump here is colin
powell
joe biden will be a president we will
all be proud to salute
with joe biden in the white house you
will never doubt that he will stand
with our friends and stand up to our
adversaries
never the other way around he will trust
our diplomats and our intelligence
community
not the flattery of dictators and
despots he will make it his job to know
when anyone dares to threaten us he will
stand up to our adversaries
with strength and experience they will
know he means business okay no one
believes joe biden means business on
foreign policy he's been one of the more
weak-kneed members of the foreign policy
establishment
for literally decades okay so then we
get to the final pitch for joe biden
so yesterday we had the joe biden's
going to help the economy pitch a little
bit
and then we had the joe biden is not
donald trump pitch which is like okay
fine that's a pitch
and then we get to the real pitch for
joe biden which is he's a nice man right
that's
that's the actual pitch for joe biden
and this is the part of the joe biden
resume
that they're trying to and that they're
trying to emphasize the most right
because donald trump is orange man bad
and he's mean and he tweets weird things
and he's a mean old
orange man who's fat and all of that
right so joe biden however by contrast
is a nice old doddering fool
he's a nice old daughter that's the case
for him that's the entire case for him
and he saw this over and over the most
effective moments of the dnc
last night and even the night before and
i'm sure tonight are going to be all the
parts where people say that joe biden is
a nice guy
and by by all accounts he is kind of a
nice guy right i mean like i've talked
to senator ted cruz on the right
megan mccain says that joe biden was
very it was it was very nice to her when
her father passed away
and people who know joe biden seemed to
like joe biden
now he is kind of an idiot who runs on
at the mouth politically but in terms of
just being like a personable guy
apparently he's a very personable guy
gets along with a lot of people in the
senate and that's basically the pitch
the pitch is do you want a nice guy at
this point now when the economy was
going gangbusters
then no one cared whether you had a nice
president or not which is why back in
march it looked like trump was going to
be elected pretty easily
now because the economy is bad people
are like it would be nice to have a nice
guy or someone who cares some now listen
this is not my brand of politics i i
don't care whether politicians care
about me because i don't deal with them
i don't think politicians should have to
care about me on an empathetic level i
think they should create policies that
get out of my way and allow me to live
my life in freedom
i don't care whether my plumber cares
about me i don't care whether my roofing
guy
cares about me all i want from him is to
do a good job it matters not to me
whether he goes home and thinks about me
day in and day out or whether he cries
with me when something bad happens in my
family because that's literally not his
job i have family for that i have a
community for that
i have religious leaders for that i've
plenty of people in my life i don't need
to fill my life with politicians who
don't
care about me i've always thought this
is the dumbest part of american politics
it really is
a newfangled growth of the modern
communications age it started probably
with fdr before that
presidents were not expected to be
captain caring that was just not their
bag
but now of course for the last hundred
years since the era of mass
communications the warmth of the
president
has meant an awful lot and that's the
part where biden has an advantage over
trump because
again people tend to look it by it and
think he's a nice guy so the most
effective parts of the dnc last night
were all about this he had
a security guard she was a security
guard at the new york times and she was
an elevator with biden
and she said i love you and joe is like
i love you back and so she actually did
the formal nomination
of joe biden last night and it was it
was really kind of sweet right it was
kind of nice
i take powerful people up on my elevator
all the time
when they get off they go to their
important meetings
me i just head back to the lobby but in
a short time i spent with joe biden i
could tell he
really saw me that he actually cared
that my life meant something to him
nominating someone like that
to be in the white house is a good place
to start
that's why i nominate my friend
joe biden as the next president of the
united states
okay so it's nice and also a little bit
condescending and when i say
condescending i just mean
that the dnc is plucking from obscurity
sort of let me introduce you
to random blue-collar worker who met joe
biden once in an elevator for 30 seconds
but
knows down to his soul what joe biden is
like as a human being now
as a politician joe biden is a vicious
knife fighter as a politician joe biden
is the guy who called mitt romney
basically a re-enslaver of black
americans and as a politician
joe biden is viciously partisan as a
politician joe biden is willing to cut
corners
he's been willing to do that for years
but as an individual interacting with
people apparently he is pretty nice
so i guess that's nice but that is the
real pitch and
when and if the pitch for biden is nice
then sort of his awkward moments become
sort of charming grandpa moments
instead of worry some oh my god what's
he going to say now moments right
there's always been the balance for joe
biden being
barely alive is that on the one hand you
want your president to be alive enough
not to constantly
be falling off of ramps and such right
and that's a reference to bob dolan 96
right in 96 bob dole
kind of fell off the stage and he was
considered too old he was 72 at the time
right joe biden is 1000 years
old so you want the balance between
being worried that the guy can't handle
the job and also the i'm comfortable
with him he's a nice old grandpa i'd let
babysit
my kids kind of feel right biden is much
warmer than hillary clinton which is one
of the reasons he's doing better in the
polls
we're gonna have hillary clinton tonight
and you'll get to see why hillary
clinton was not made president of the
united states
uh so there were a lot of moments last
night where biden was awkward but it was
more charming than it was kind of
off-putting so here was biden learning
he got the nomination
and it was real awkward and weird but
again he's sort of charming grandpa and
at least that's the way the media is
portraying him
he really looks mostly like grandpa
who's been surprised with a birthday
cake by the grandchild doesn't really
know kind of what's going on
but it's real cute he's going to take
photos with the kitties
[Music]
[Applause]
library
and then yep weird zoom clapping for
we're good
from all the delegates it was all very
all very odd and joe biden
kind of wide-eyed i mean he's giving the
same look that my grandmother
gives us when we give her a surprise
party which is i don't know what's going
on but i know i'm supposed to be happy
right now a lot of that from joe biden
but looking sort of this was played as
more charming than a little frightening
that joe isn't completely aware of his
surroundings
again then cindy mccain came forth and
cindy mccain talked about how
joe was always a wonderful guy with john
again this is the pitch the pitch is
that joe is a nice person
even if a deal seemed out of reach it
was always
joe who tried to cross the aisle for
three decades
joe was able to move his colleagues and
find a way forward
on violence against women banning
chemical weapons
assault weapons and controlling nuclear
arms
it was a style of legislating and
leadership that you don't find much
anymore okay now by the way that is
exactly the style of leadership the
democrats no longer embrace so it's kind
of funny to pitch that
again they're pitching joe biden from 40
years ago when he was making
criminal justice bills not the joe biden
of today who's being
pushed around in a wheelchair by by
nancy pelosi and
bernie sanders and aoc okay then there
was the best pitch again the best pitch
is the personal pitch for joe biden
jill biden was great last night okay she
was flat-out good okay so joe biden
was making the only case that you can
make for joe which is that he's a nice
guy you can't make the case that he's
alive because he barely
is you cannot make the case that he is
competent because he really
is not and when other people make the
case for joe biden it's always slightly
awkward
and basically michelle obama's case for
joe biden is i should be the nominee but
joe biden is the dead guy over there and
he's the one you nominated so really do
him instead of trump please
right that was really the pitch and then
the pitch from kamala harris tonight
presumably will be
well you know if joe dies i'll be here
so let's do that let's let's do that
jill biden is the only one who can make
an authentic case on behalf of joe
because she's been married to that
guy for 30 years and been listening to
his diarrhea of the mouth for the last
three decades so she does in fact
like him so having somebody who likes
shabbat and talking about how he's
likable makes some sense
i thought joe biden came off as very
authentic i thought that she came off
uh as as very nice so she talked about
joe biden and personal tragedy which is
the most affecting part of his story
this is a person
who lost children in a car crash early
on in his uh in his life
and then obviously he just lost his son
to brain cancer i mean these are serious
personal tragedies and it does humanize
people humanizing joe biden has always
been an easier task than humanizing
hillary clinton who's a velociraptor of
a human being
so jill biden did what i thought was a
very good job
she seems like a nice lady i mean really
like
she does uh and here was joe biden being
a nice lady talking about her nice
husband
and someone put it last night there the
kooky couple the kooky couple from next
door
on the sitcom where you might wander
into their apartment by accident and uh
they're elderly people
making weird kinds of love it was really
they have that vibe
to them from the from the 1970s three's
company era
here was jill biden talking about the
wonders of joe
four days after beau's funeral i watched
joe
shave and put on his suit i saw him
steal himself in the mirror take a
breath
put his shoulders back and walk out
into a world empty of our son
he went back to work that's just who he
is okay so so all of this stuff was very
good for him right because
again the case for joe's he's a nice old
guy and he won't leave you alone again
this is part of the tacit promise that
the chaos stops of joe's elected
president
so there is a soft blackmail underneath
the entire democratic pitch but
again the key for joe biden is turning
him into a human
anytime you talk about any other aspect
of joe biden it's a bad thing for him
you talk about his policies it's bad you
talk about his party it's bad you talk
about his vp it's bad
the only thing that democrats want to
focus in on is empathy
and joe biden and his captain feelings
and all the rest of this that's why
the part of joe biden's speech i thought
that fell a little flat is when she
talked about how the schools were all
closed because of covet and i was
thinking to myself they don't have to be
i mean really they don't have to be it
is democratic politicians who are saying
that we can't open up schools
again even though children are not dying
of covet they are not dying of covet the
numbers demonstrate they are not
transmitting coven in large numbers
but joe biden blames trump for the
schools not being open even though it is
mainly blue states that are keeping the
schools closed
right florida is opening up the schools
california aid in fact california is
suing to stop private schools from
opening
here is joe biden though pretending that
it's trump's fault the schools aren't
opening
this quiet is heavy
you can hear the anxiety that echoes
down empty hallways
there's no scent of new notebooks or
freshly waxed floors
the rooms are dark as the bright young
faces
that should fill them are now confined
to
boxes on a computer screen
okay so this is a um this is a weird
kind of off-putting pitch from joe biden
but all the stuff about her husband
was not quite as off-putting and then of
course joe biden blew the ending right
again this was giving daughter and
grandpa
his birthday present and his birthday
present is a subscription to the aarp
news magazine here was here is joe biden
blowing the ending he comes in at the
very end and he mushmouths it and and
like people thought he said i'm joe
biden's husband he says i'm jill biden's
husband but he can't articulate and so
i don't know it's the dentures or what
he he literally i mean he just
completely blows this and looks all odd
and weird and
he's just walking into classrooms now
and it was very strange
hey everyone i'm jill biden's husband
as you heard tonight excuse me you can
see why she's the love of my life
the rock of our family she never gives
herself much credit but the truth is
she's the strongest person i know just
think of your favorite educator who gave
you the confidence to believe in
yourself
that's the kind of first lady lady lady
lady
this jill biden will be what's going on
lady lady lady lady lady lady lady okay
so
the record got stuck and then they had
to kind of you know hit the record
machine and get the thing to stop
s skipping and scratching uh so again
that's the pitch the pitch is joe biden
is a person who is alive and is nice
according to his wife
if that's your pitch go for it i mean
really it's it is a pitch
i i suppose if that's what you're
looking for then uh that is what you
will get
all right we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content and
of course we'll be back here tomorrow to
recap
night three of the democratic national
convention when we expect to hear
from the wondrous presidentis of the
united states hillary clinton still
wandering the woods of chappaqua
in complete bewilderment she is not in
fact president and a
person nearly as charmless as hillary
clinton kamala harris
she of the joker gaffa and the
prosecution of small children they can
expect all sorts of good times tonight
so stick around for more show later
today and then we'll be here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinnerton
edited by adam sciovets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020
killer cuomo writes a book on lockdown
leadership bill clinton talks about
bucking in the oval office
and fake republicans endorse biden at
the dnc check it out at the michael
knowles show
[Music]
you